are you bored do you need to escape
everyday life do you want to know how to
fix your bike use your iPhone or make
the perfect Cheese Souffle well then you
need to get yourself along to your local
why maca dairy library we have
[Applause]
picture books graphic novels large print
audio yes it's fair to say we have a ton
of wonderful books but did you know at
Waimakariri libraries books just the tip
of the iceberg Ford could well get them
to join our Liga club book club or any
of our school holiday activities or
family night for adults we have a wide
range of jigsaws games for grown-ups
movie mornings and an extensive
selection of DVDs for your listening
pleasure we also have CDs girl law and
we host concerts by local and touring
musicians to art galleries with ever
changing exhibitions that will blow your
socks off but wait there's more at
Weimer canary libraries we're nothing if
not practical you name it we've got it
here's just some of our many services
available are you feeling stuck confused
frustrated about those little things
perhaps you don't know how to navigate
word or maybe Facebook just confuses you
well look no further our book a
librarian service is just what you need
you can book quality one-on-one time
with the librarian or why not try one of
our stepping up workshops that run
throughout the year think libraries are
outdated no one we have a vast online e
resource we have books for young and old
audio books newspapers magazines
lynda.com you name it
whichever wherever you are you can take
your library with you can make it and
Judis sickness or injury our service
books and homes will deliver free of
charge
but wait there's more if you join
Waimakariri libraries today or any day
your membership is absolutely free so
what are you waiting for come and join
your library today Waimakariri libraries
making the world a better place